so you think about putting the band back
together huh but I don't think that
group will work out stop acting like you
don't miss it I mean the women the
cheers the tits the tips I do but how
you gonna do that with your leg my
dancing days is over but I got a ringer
[Music]
hey I'm not a clown
listen you need to tell your face
I am tired of sneaking men in the last
one I had there was so loud when I let
them come in my back door I was scared
he was gonna wake you up I don't got no
back door
I got you something you needed Mom
thanks but it's a one-way ticket there's
only one way you're gonna do this Merlin
your way
Once Upon a Time May the finest male
dancing troop in town the chocolate
chips
it was a gold mine Mr face Mr body Mr
Slim sexy Dr X and the one and only
Mr Big
why don't you go get ready you got a
tough crowd waiting for you
in Vegas
are you seeing what I'm seeing me back
in business you haven't talked to the
chips in years how are you gonna find
them
you out of your goddamn mind excuse me
Lord
to be the stupidest idea I ever heard in
my life
quadruplets
we have fun back then
let's give it up for Dr Xander Pike
Santa's right Gus the mask and the flat
ass it's time for you to get on stage
and do it your way
turn
[Music]
without further Ado ladies the chocolate
it's showtime brother
[Music]
hey that's not what a bang guys
up too high yeah he over banging
[Music]